are we rolling yet because I have some
things I need to say to Rich
for round two is the ever inspiring one
and only queen of grounded
science-backed personal development my
dear friend Mel Robbins the research is
conclusive that when you are critical of
yourself it destroys all motivation to
act Mel is crazy talented she's super
authentic and just has this knack for
cutting through the noise and the
[ __ ] and telling you exactly what
you need to hear to get off your butt
and in to action my mission is super
simple it's very very much a the same as
yours it's to help you create a better
life
she does it with a smile she does it
with compassion and wisdom born from a
lifetime of both success and more
importantly epic failures
if you have a bad day congratulations
you're breathing you're a human being
please
do not beat yourself up
shake it off and pick something you're
going to do tomorrow Mel is a former
lawyer turned CNN legal analyst talk
show host Mega best-selling author of
the five second rule in the high five
habit and one of the most widely booked
public speakers in the world and after
absolutely dominating in the world of
audible only audiobooks Mel is now
branching out into my territory with the
launch of her brand new podcast aptly
titled the Mel Robbins podcast which
immediately upon launch skyrocketed no
surprise to one of the top shows in the
world I deeply believe that you can heal
generalized anxiety something I've
struggled with for almost 45 years so
buckle your proverbial seat belt open
your hearts and enjoy this enlightening
Exchange
Mel Robbins
so I cannot believe you just said that
you feel guilty
about making people drive out here to
your students it's a commitment we it's
way out in the middle of nowhere
it's cool I'm glad you're here it's
complete [ __ ] first of all you have
this incredible platform that you have
built you have people that hang on your
every word and it is absolutely like a
gift that you're giving to people so the
fact that you would feel guilty about
somebody spending 45 measly minutes to
be able to come and have a conversation
it was probably more like an hour hardly
but it doesn't matter I don't know stop
that okay yeah well this is kind of like
we're going to talk about tangential
issues around you know this kind of
mental ailment yes and so let me point
out another one of yours yeah so this
morning I was looking on Instagram and
you put up the post about Zac Efron
right being a fan of your show and you
said I might take this down later and
all of your fans I held back because I
knew I was going to tell you this in
person we're like stop if you didn't
actually make a difference in the world
then he would not be doing what he's
doing in terms of the the way he's
gotten his health in order and so you
make a huge difference and you call it
self-promotional but the truth is you
are creating
positive Ripple effects and I think it's
very inspiring
that you do that and so I don't see it
as promotional at all I see it as you
demonstrating the reach of your show and
the fact that the people that you have
on change the lives of real people and
that has a huge impact on the world dude
well I appreciate that I'm gonna click
now I can clip that out and I'll put
that up on Instagram let him I'm now
talking to Rich's team Mel Robbins will
drive back here and literally yell at
everybody I'm telling you like you are
you are humble which I deeply admire and
it's something that you know I might not
be sounding humble right now but you and
I share that sort of like ah Shucks
thing because we didn't get into this
in terms of podcasts or writing books or
doing what we're doing because we had
some aspiration to become a celebrity we
have been sharing our stories because I
think both you and I believe that first
of all if we can do it
you can do it and secondly that there
are simple things that you can do to
become happier or healthier and that if
you and I can save anybody the [ __ ]
headache and heartaches that we both
caused ourselves
that is a life well lived I'm on your
page with that and you know I appreciate
everything that you just shared and and
I am trying to grow into you know the
person who can kind of just gracefully
accept nice things when they're when
they're said to me as opposed to you
know every Instinct inside of me which
is to say yeah but or to diminish you
know the the kind things I think in the
case of you know uh publishing like a
something that really is unabashedly
very self-promotional I mean on its face
that's what it is right there is inside
of me a thing like like the only reason
I'm putting this up it's like it's
shining a light on me and I have
discomfort with that like I'd rather
make it about what you just said which
is the ideas behind it yeah but you are
making it about the ideas
because you don't sit here and have the
conversations and do all the work behind
the scenes
that you do that most people are not
aware of that go into making this form
of Art and this act of service that
you're doing for the World by hosting
this podcast by producing it by putting
it out there rich
and I think that what's really cool
about putting out that post about Zac
Efron giving you credit right for
everything that he knows about health
for training for Baywatch for the stuff
that he's learned from you that you're
the person that he listens to is that he
has a big platform and so he can then
send that ripple effect even further and
so the other thing I wanted to say
because this is going to lead us right
into the topic about mental health about
mindset about happiness and the the
profound issues I've been working on in
my own life is I
completely understand what you mean when
you say it's really hard to accept a
compliment it's hard to accept a gift
you'd rather have it be about somebody
else
one of the biggest breakthroughs I've
had in the last couple years rich is
this Epiphany about my inability to
receive love and the fact that I was
uncomfortable for a long time
hearing a compliment or having somebody
say something nice or having a birthday
party thrown for me or receiving a gift
and I have recently had this
breakthrough because I have learned that
there is a extremely tight connection
between feeling anxious and not allowing
love to come in and so I have this
visual rich and I'm going to explain
this to you because
um I just had this emotional experience
happen when you sort of were like
pushing away the love I was trying to to
to shower you with
so
I think when you block love like imagine
like there's this closed door
and when somebody tries to link with you
or connect with you or authentically
tell you how amazing you are if you have
a hard time hearing it you basically
have put a solid door between you and
the other person
and I've been working recently with
visualizing The Galley doors in a
kitchen That Swing both ways because
you're very good at giving love you're
very good at giving support you're an
incredibly amazing friend because you're
always there when somebody needs you and
you always open the door to listen to
advise to share
and I'm the same way too and for a long
time when somebody would try to give it
back to me the door was closed so let's
talk a little bit about where that comes
from like what is the Genesis of that
instinct for you or what have you
learned about what I've learned about
this and I would strongly encourage you
to bring Dr Russell Kennedy onto your
show he wrote the book anxiety RX he's a
medical doctor who also got his degree
in neuroscience and he started
experiencing anxiety when he was in
medical school and he
um has gone on to heal his anxiety he
treats people around the world with
anxiety like he is a game changer on
this content and the topic of anxiety
so his theory and I now see this
completely in my life his theory is that
all anxiety comes from childhood and it
comes from the experience of being
separate in childhood and so every
single one of us has an experience and
you may not remember it because 80 of
your brain is formed by the time you're
five years old but you have an
experience where you as a kid feel
distinct and separate from your
caregiver and he talks a lot about this
concept of a parental mismatch so there
are a lot of us that have parents who
are wonderful people or maybe they're
not wonderful people but you have
parents who are wonderful people but for
you emotionally just like the five love
languages there can be a mismatch in
terms of the love language you speak and
need and what your partner does that
your parent and the way that they
provide emotional support is a mismatch
and so as a kid when you don't get the
reassurance you need or when you don't
feel loved or seen or heard or accepted
you feel separate from the parent that
you're biologically hardwired and
needing to bond with which also means
you feel unsafe and so as a little kid
at some point an alarm would go off in
your body whenever you felt separate
from your parents and it could be as
innocuous as go hug your uncle and
you're like this I don't want to hug my
uncle you're like get in there
um or don't do that now I'm busy or the
snapping at you and you immediately feel
that alarm because you feel separate
and so what happens is that this alarm
that starts going off and going off and
going off in moments where you feel
separate you're not feeling the love
that you need you're not feeling
connected you're not feeling reassured
it starts to go off all the time
now as you get older and older and older
I mean we've all had the experience of
walking in to see old friends at lunch
and for many of us we feel that alarm go
off they've all arrived there they're
all talking you feel that sense of
Separation that's anxiety
that's what it is it's in your body and
it is according to Dr Kennedy it is the
little you
basically waving their hand saying I
need a little reassurance right now
that's all that it is
and for decades I have approached what
has been an experience of living with
anxiety
from the neck up I mean the five second
rule is a neck up approach and based on
the last two years of intense therapy
that I've been in and you know a lot of
stuff that I've recently learned from Dr
Kennedy
I realize it is
fundamentally a neck down issue
that attacking anxiety and these moments
where you feel separate or scared or you
feel the alarm go off in your body if
you instead of treating it like a signal
that something's wrong if you actually
treat it as a signal
that you just need a little bit of love
from yourself right now just put your
hand on your heart you can like take a
towel and kind of do this on your back
rub it back and forth and you feel like
you're hugging yourself take a deep
breath tell yourself whatever you need
to hear in that moment in order to
reassure yourself that you're going to
be okay or that whatever you know I get
it you know you feel a little nervous
but all those people at that table love
you
it's freaking bonkers
how powerful of a purchase is and it's
also made me realize that wow
I am so not used to giving myself that
kind of love and reassurance
no wonder I'm uncomfortable letting
other people give it to me um
that's powerful I mean a couple sort of
Reflections on that the first being uh
that it tracks in a very similar way to
uh science that's emerging on the nature
of trauma like I've just had a couple
episodes with gabarmate and Dr Paul
Conte and both of them they have their
approaches are a little bit different
but they they have this shared shared
sense or a shared uh perspective that
that trauma arises in early childhood
and for the same reasons you're you
weren't the parenting match wasn't
appropriate or correct
um
and it makes me wonder whether kind of
all of these things that we experience
later in life where we feel off-kilter
can be tracked back to those very early
years and it's interesting I'm surprised
I think that all in fact I start get I'm
now I'm so
uh deep in my own personal exploration
of the somatic modalities whether it's
the I the the cold exposure which has
been a game changer for me in many ways
and I still hate whether it's guided
MDMA therapy sessions with my husband
which has been incredible around nervous
system regulation and being able to
re-experience past trauma in a
controlled setting that allows my body
to reprocess it so it doesn't keep
triggering me
um EMDR but I'm telling you just this
reframe of thinking about anxiety as not
a neck up approach of course cognitive
behavioral therapy works of course talk
therapy is super important of course
things like the five second rule and
pattern Interruption and working on
different ways of thinking in terms of
interrupting the self-criticism with a
little bit more encouragement that stuff
is part of the toolkit but I deeply
believe that you can heal generalized
anxiety
something I've struggled with for almost
45 years I believe that through learning
how to experience that alarm that goes
off that is completely normal when you
feel separate when you feel invisible
when you feel slightly nervous and
learning how to give yourself the love
and the reassurance that you didn't get
at whatever moment it was that this
alarm started going off sub five years
old
I think this is game changing it has
been for me I've now taught it to two of
my kids that are uh that struggle with
anxiety they're reporting back like okay
why didn't you know this like when I was
eight and the doctor kept saying change
the channel like just being able to
silence the alarm and realize oh this
thing can come and go I don't have to be
ruled by it it's freaking awesome the
feeling of of being different than or an
outsider or other than and that you know
kind of low-grade uh nervousness that
comes with walking into a room of people
and not really knowing how to connect
and feeling like you're on the outside
of that I mean this is the story of my
life I've never really couched it or
thought of it in the context of anxiety
I thought of it more I mean now and I've
said this a million times so forgive me
but you know I kind of perceive all of
these things through the lens of of
addiction and recovery and the tools
that I've learned you know through many
years of being in in in that rubric and
in that Community to make me feel more
integrated and over many years of
practicing those tools and you know
creating a life for myself where I do
feel more self-actualized and kind of uh
with that comes a sense of self-esteem
that has ameliorated you know 95 of that
feeling that you know I used to have
that made it impossible for me to be
around other people and why I medicated
for so many years
um but I still have some low-grade
aspect of that I've just never really
thought of it as a chronic anxiety as
much as just a a feeling of like
dissonance it's the same thing because
the dissidence or the uh like my biggest
experience with anxiety was
disassociation
so when I felt separate or I felt like
nervous about something and I and I and
I didn't understand that all I needed in
that moment was reassurance I would like
mentally leave the room in my body and
so one of the other interesting things
the more that you look into research
around anxiety is there is an
extraordinary connection between anxiety
and addiction
and the reason why is because if you
don't know what to do with that alarm
that is simply the little you going hey
can you just give me a hug right now and
tell me we're going to be okay
um
you find ways to silence it and so for
you alcohol and addiction for my husband
a daily weed habit like he never thought
of himself as somebody that had anxiety
either but what Chris was dealing with
in those moments when the alarm was
going off my my response to the anxiety
alarm is is fight go go go go go go
which is why my addiction was an
addiction to busyness and to work and to
trying to outrun it my husband's
response to that alarm that goes off
inside you when you feel separate or you
feel nervous about something or you feel
uncertain or overwhelmed was to freeze
and to withdraw and so it became so
intolerable for him that feeling of
being separate that he would hit you
know the wheat pen every day I didn't
even know this as a way to silence the
alarm and so you know I think that that
when you start to talk about it not as
anxiety but as an alarm that has been
with many of us since childhood that
feeling of being separate or getting
triggered by these subtle moments where
you feel like you're on the outside
looking in I mean I think a lot of
people find it hard to believe that
somebody who puts themselves out there
the way that I do I was actually pretty
shy as a kid and my childhood best
friend just has a big laugh because
she's like most people don't realize you
were like this awkward weird little kid
you were shy you were always kind of off
you were never like with a big group of
friends and I still as an adult feel
that that way even when I'm welcomed
into big groups of people or you know I
I do much better one-on-one with people
well let's let's drill down on the
busyness thing you know on some level I
suppose that's analogous to workaholism
uh and it and it's rooted in this drive
that that you know was created very
early in life and translates into this
you know busyness also what comes with
that the drive the ambition the
competitiveness all of these things and
I share all of these traits with you
that you know as we get older we learn
to be proud of and credit with our
success but also become unsustainable
energy sources that end up wreaking all
kinds of havoc and mask that anxiety or
kind of distract us from really looking
inward to
kind of course correcting what's not
serving us so I would say my primary
addiction
that I still struggle with is busyness
an addiction to being busy and I would
classify
at least the busyness that I've
experienced in three different
categories
so there is the busyness that comes from
transactional love and transactional
acceptance and worth and I don't think
that necessarily is something that
happens in adulthood I think most of us
learn it as kids that when you get good
grades or you excel in sports or you do
what makes your parents happy that's
when you get the positive attention that
we also desperately need when we're
growing up validation that our existence
is worthy of love and praise and so when
you start to recognize that acting the
way that your folks want you to act or
getting good grades or doing great in
sports or doing what makes everybody
happy that that's what gives you that
emotional support that creates a certain
kind of achievement a busyness a chasing
of something outside of you because you
were trained as a kid that that's how
you got positive emotional feedback so
that's one kind of a business and it's
why so many of us
find ourselves putting all of our worth
outside of ourselves because we were
trained to believe that if we're doing
something worthy of Praise then we get
the emotional support that we need so
that's one kind of busyness and for sure
I absolutely have that absolutely and it
has been wonderful in many regards
because that kind of drive that kind of
ambition that that can be very very
successful it can it can make you very
very successful the second kind of
busyness uh is another kind of busyness
and that's a busyness that's born out of
crisis
and so you know a lot of My Success came
at a moment in time where my husband and
I were about to lose everything
I told the story the first time that I
was here on the podcast and you know
when you can't pay your bills and you're
about to lose your house and everything
is on the line there is a level of
busyness that is motivated by sheer need
and so I also had this problem Rich
where when
I started getting booked for speeches
we had liens on our house
so I became very very busy because I was
in the middle of a crisis
and the problem with that kind of
busyness is it's very hard
to hit the brakes
and to go I'm not in a crisis anymore in
fact I think that based on a lot of the
you know this you and I both do a ton of
speaking on the corporate circuit and
what I've noticed even coming out of the
pandemic is that every single company
and person
in the world had an over-functioning
anxiety response to the pandemic the
second it hit and we were all in
quarantine and everything is uncertain
everybody's like go go go go go go go go
zoom zoom zoom zoom zoom zoom zoom
change change pivot pivot pivot and most
companies have not gotten out of that
mode because it's a busyness that was
created in response to a crisis
and so there's this huge moment right
now that everybody needs to step on the
brakes and go wait a minute
I can't keep responding
to day-to-day life like it's a crisis
not everything requires a zoom meeting
not everything requires us to work all
day long I got to go back to getting
focused on what matters and being
strategic and thoughtful rather than
driven by this like anxiousness Well
there's almost a PTSD to it it's my
version of your story you know what I
relate to that deeply we I went through
something very similar and was once we
emerged out of it and everything
stabilized it was very difficult for me
to slow down because I was so
desperately afraid of ever being in that
situation again that I was just pushing
the accelerator as hard as I possibly
could to get as far away as I possibly
could from ever being that person with
this sense that if I even eased up a bit
that the whole house of cards was going
to topple on top of me and it took me a
long time to kind of exhale and realize
like yes I'm not in a crisis anymore
everything is working fine you can you
know breathe and you know it's now
incumbent upon you to kind of deal with
that anxiety or that post-traumatic
stress or however you would qualify it
and transcend it and overcome it and
that was not that was not an easy thing
well at the same time because you're
getting you are growing and you're
getting that external validation and
things are working and so there's a
there's a you have like a feverish you
know kind of relationship with that
because
um the outside world is praising you for
it which makes it more difficult to slow
down I remember when somebody I told a
bunch of people that you and I know that
I would I had decided that I was no
longer going to be speaking on the
corporate circuit
and somebody looked at me and said why
on Earth
would you stop
giving Keynotes right and just deposit
for a moment for people that don't know
you're like the number one
self-improvement motivational speaker on
the circuit you were commanding insane
fees and there was no shortage of of
companies that wanted to book you so you
could go on the road and just you know
Bank like serious life-changing cash
I did for years and you know in this and
and I but I wasn't happy
like again it was being driven by this
addiction to being busy and the fact
that just like you like my success was
born out of a crisis and so I was trying
to outrun that crisis and build as much
buffer as I could and I'm grateful for
the experience I'm grateful that I could
pay off the loans I'm grateful to be in
a position
um that I'm in now uh with with savings
and to be able to pay for college and to
be able to go on nice trips but I wasn't
[ __ ] happy
I'd missed all of our daughter's High
School experience
and I felt deeply disconnected from my
husband and I just was exhausted and
somebody looked at me and they said but
you
like are in a category of one in this
why would you give it up and I'm like it
just doesn't make me happy and I think
that's part of how you get out of
that mode of the second form of busy
which is that pts response that we all
had PTSD response that we all had to
quarantine and to the world turning
upside down like I personally believe
that unless you are somebody that has
been working on your nervous system
regulation I personally feel and this is
not a medical opinion this is just Mel
Robbins opinion that when the quarantine
hit and the pandemic hit
the universe flipped the switch on
everybody's nervous system
and everybody because we were going
through an unprecedented experience
your nervous system went into fight or
flight the alarm turned on
as you don't know whether you can bring
groceries inside masks everywhere we're
not going back to school now it's one
month now it's two months now it's three
months uncertainty and we're not Built
For This
and I believe almost everybody listening
unless you are actively working on your
nervous system regulation
that you have a major opportunity
to do some simple things to flip the
switch off
and switch off your uh sympathetic nerve
which would it would the parasympathetic
nervous system
right and flip on the parasympathetic I
always I always get them mixed up
because I think if it's sympathetic it
should be the one that makes you relax
sympathetic I'm probably wrong but I
think the sympathetic nervous system is
the fight-or-flight yeah which is which
seems screwy to me but so I feel like
you know if you think about it
in the walls of your studio there's all
kinds of wiring for electricity that
wiring is your nervous system
and what happened for many of us whether
it's because of the pandemic or because
of childhood trauma you've never
addressed or because of some traumatic
incident or chronic abuse whatever it
may be the lights have always been on
and you know how some lights are like
um
if you feel on edge if you feel like
you're waiting for the next shoe to drop
you have an opportunity to just start to
see that alarm going off in the
background
and to give yourself the reassurance
and the love that you need
to flip the switch to go back to your
calm cool resting state and there are
simple things that you can do all of
which you talk about extensively on the
show whether it's cold exposure
whether it's meditation whether it's
exercise whether it's breathing
exercises but even the stuff related to
toning the vagus nerve
but I think one of the greatest access
points is truly understanding that that
alarm is just that little kid in you who
had experiences when you were little
that you don't necessarily remember that
made you feel scared separate alone
uncertain and nobody reassured you
the first step though is recognizing
that it exists within you because we
have a tremendous capacity to normalize
whatever our experience is and so we
could be completely off kilter or just
so acclimated to a level of chronic
anxiety or whatever the case may be that
it becomes difficult to even recognize
in ourselves because we've just lived
with it for so long yeah and you know
when you realize it's not
about being nervous
like the alarm that you feel on your
body could be expressed as anger it
could be expressed as frustration
because you can't tolerate that
discomfort that's going off in your body
it might be expressed as withdrawing it
might be expressed as you know being on
edge like somebody you know like me
which was my experience of feeling
always like something bad was about to
happen but then there's a third busyness
and this is the one that has really been
kind of a real game changer for me Rich
um I caught the campaign of misery
may surprise you to know that is
positive
and is optimistic of a person you know
that I am and I I do believe I'm a very
positive person I'm a very optimistic
person meaning that I do believe that
your attitude and your actions can have
it can improve any situation that you're
facing I had in the background a
constant campaign of misery
that was a tape playing in the back of
my mind
and if you grew up around anybody that
complains or gripes or life is hard or
gossips or just is pointing out what's
wrong or unhappy you don't realize it
but it becomes the language you speak to
yourself it's how you keep yourself
company
and when I started to truly
go both you know attacking my thoughts
but more importantly when I started to
go neck down and I started to realize
this alarm is something I don't want to
live with anymore this alarm going off
all the time not something I'm going to
tolerate and I started to take the steps
to find the switch inside me and to
silence that alarm going off of my body
what I noticed rich is holy [ __ ]
when I'm not paying attention
the place that my mind goes is to what's
wrong and the more that I fix the
outside [ __ ] like you know I we pay off
our bills we start saving money we are
moving to Vermont and and renovating
this house and I'm working on my
marriage and things are really good and
the more that the outside stuff is good
the louder the campaign of misery
actually turned inward at me well it's
got to latch on to something yes if
that's your default disposition I didn't
realize how much my
mind scanned for what was wrong
and so it's this third form of busyness
where you yourself in your own mind are
like pointing out the things that aren't
good enough like I literally would be
sitting in this house that Chris and I
built complete dream house you've been
there and
instead of being able to truly look at
the view down the valley
my mind would go yeah well but there's
no people here you're not going to have
any friends you thought you were lonely
in Boston just wait like it's like the
alarm yeah is trying to come back in
fairness it is in the middle of nowhere
okay now don't make me nervous does that
mean you're not going to come visit see
now I'm panicked again everything was
when the alarm wasn't going off it was
as if this campaign of misery was trying
to flip it back on and that's the thing
I'm working on now
I feel like most people want to eat
better they want to improve their diets
absolutely have you heard of it I've
heard of it this trips up so many people
we thought hey we know a couple things
about how to do this a few so we created
this thing called the plant power meal
planner that is this beautiful offering
whereby you gain access to literally
thousands of plant-based recipes that
you can totally customize based upon
your preferences your allergies your
peccadillos it integrates with grocery
delivery so all the ingredients that you
need get shipped right to your door so
you can make the stuff that you've
pre-selected and we all could use a
little inspiration and support when
preparing meals for our families in our
busy lives so we hope you join us no
matter what your eating style is we have
our arms open wide and we've saved you a
space at our family table to join us in
eating more healthy vibrant plant-based
meals and if you're looking for the
perfect holiday gift for a loved one
right now for limited time we're
offering twenty dollars off meal planner
gift cards through December 15th visit
meals.ritroll.com to claim the offer
again for twenty dollars off meal
planner gift cards from now until
December 15th visit meals dot
richroll.com
so what was the the Breaking Point with
that that that that compelled you to to
reckon with it
it was uh during well I think that it's
I'll tell you the breaking point it was
during a guided MDMA session yeah I want
to get into this we I wanted to put a
pin in that but if that's relevant to
this let's hear about this well I have
been
uh working with a therapist for two
years
uh on just healing past trauma on
um
trying to figure out how to be more
content accepting and happy
with wherever I am instead of constantly
grinding for the next thing
and between that talk therapy between
the therapy that Chris and I are doing
um once he got diagnosed with long-term
like depression
um and EMDR and like I think all of it
was compounding to this one breaking
point so my husband and I have done uh
two guided therapeutic MDMA sessions
with uh this couple I can't name them
because it's not legal in the state that
we were in
but they're part of the maps protocol
and part of a huge integrative therapy
community that is doing the post
integration therapy after these sort of
uh you know psychedelic experiences
which I think is the most important part
of these experiences is the therapy that
you do afterwards to integrate what you
experienced physically mentally
spiritually emotionally back into your
life so um we've already done one it was
absolute Game Changer fantastic so here
we are 18 months later this was in April
and we're doing a second one and so the
way that it works is you set an
intention
you then take the
um the MDM the MDMA and uh it takes
about 30 to 45 minutes to kick in and I
had done ecstasy at concerts or just
recreationally this is a completely
different experience because once you
start to feel this sort of warm wave
take over you immediately go to a
separate like mattress or mat or cot or
whatever and you climb in under blankets
and you've got all these amazing pillows
and then you put on a mask and then you
put on headphones
and there's a six hour playlist and it's
the most delicious amazing incredible
like Buddha Bar Meats I don't know what
kind of stuff and they say that the
um you know that the the MDMA is the
medicine but the music is the guide
and with every song change
what happened to me the first time I did
this is I would have a completely
different image in my mind it was as if
because you're you're uh vision is
blocked and because you know you have
all of this like amazing music coming in
the MDMA is a game changer because it
blocks the amygdala so you have no fear
reaction
and so what happened for me the first
time I did it is it was the most
profound experience of my life
for six hours I witnessed the Highlight
Reel of my past present and future
and I didn't just watch it I actually
was there and so the first song comes on
and it's like I am you know that Space
Mountain ride uh where you're in the
dark at Disney and then it comes around
a corner and you're it was a feeling
like that and then all of a sudden the
clouds broke and there I was I was uh at
Bear Lake in North Muskegon Michigan
where I grew up and I was in the eighth
grade and I was there with my best
friend Jody the one who says I'm shy and
we had the jam box out there and journey
was playing and I like felt the whole
thing I was there again and my intention
for the first uh MDMA therapy session
was I want to look back on my life and
remember the good stuff I mean our
brains are a real [ __ ] with this
negativity bias and the fact that you
remember the bad things that happened
like I don't know if it's 3x or 5x to
the good things I'm like please show me
the beauty in my life and so that was
the first thing and then the song
changed and the second vision
was
um I could see like little baby feet
and I looked up and there was this big
beautiful blue sky with these big clouds
and there were kites everywhere rich
and then I looked straight ahead
and there's my mom
and she was 19 years old
and there was my dad
and he was 23.
and I felt this wave come over me
they were so
Young
and you know I love my mom and she loves
me but we have a very kind of mismatched
sort of the way that we express
and I know that she feels in many ways
that she gave up on her life because she
dropped out on of college to have me
and for the first time
I I just felt this huge intense wave of
love and I reached for the therapist
that was sitting with me and I'm like I
can't handle this I can't handle this I
can't and I started sobbing and then I
and she just put her hands on my chest
and was just like you know tell me
what's happening and breathe into it and
I felt this crazy amount of
just
sorrow and and love
that I had never felt in just at a soul
level
for how scared she must have been and
this was in the first experience that
you had and that and this is relevant
because it's great to hear about it yeah
and that experience was a vivid memory
like you were actually in that place oh
yeah
and then for you were able to access a
memory from being a baby yes in stored
here because what happens with this
music is it on whatever is going on with
this music and this like the MDMA is it
unlocks
something in your subconscious that you
can't access for whatever reason
at least this is the way I explain it
God knows if that's what's actually
happening but so for six hours rich like
it was past present future I've already
been to my daughter's wedding I I have
been there I've I've seen it I know
exactly I travel to the future I did you
did oh I did
and so
the next day as we were driving home I
called my mom and I'm like you know I I
had this thing where we did this therapy
session and you know I saw you and Dad
and there were a lot of kites and she
immediately went oh that's such and such
Park in Kansas City
I've never seen a photo of this rich
said they would always fly kites and do
this and airplanes and stuff yeah we
used to go there every you know Saturday
afternoon when your dad was off call wow
and so that was remarkable and I had
this experience of literally like almost
like my nervous system smoothing out and
so for the second time I was so excited
oh my God you know we're moving to
Vermont we thought we would do this to
like start the new chapter this is going
to be amazing meanwhile I've been doing
all this therapy and I'm working so hard
on trying to get that alarm to turn off
I have not yet learned the connection
between being separate as a child and
separation anxiety and all anxiety is
adult I have not learned the connection
between this alarm and the little you
just needing love
and so we go into the second uh session
and this time we're going to do it at
our brand new home the first day we move
in Chris is again with you know it's a
husband and wife therapy team he's with
the husband I'm with the wife we set an
intention and I say I want to look to
the Future
and I want to really enjoy this next
chapter of my life I want to stop like
just and so they say that the medicine
gives you exactly what you need
so
30 minutes goes I'm feeling the warm
thing I'm climbing in got my little
blanket up I put my head and here's the
other cool thing I've never had any
interest in doing Ayahuasca because I
don't I'm like I don't want to [ __ ] or
puke like that that is not right that
does not make me feel excited about this
I don't want to feel out of control I'm
scared about scary things and so what I
loved also about the MDMA is that the
second you take your eye mask off to go
to the bathroom
you're out of it
even though the drug is still coursing
through your veins out of it you know
when I have to go the bathroom you know
I'm like I I need to help go in the
bathroom and I literally stood up take
the eye mask off nove nothing so there's
something about the Sonic wavelengths
and the visual experience and the yes
yeah it's incredible and then the whole
time you're going to the bathroom you're
like I gotta get back I gotta get back
because so the second time I climb in
and I'm expecting this to be this
amazing highlight reel
nothing happens
so I'm laying there I'm like like is
this gonna work what's going on
reaching for the the gal the therapist I
I don't think he gave me enough is Chris
is Chris tripping is is he oh he's he's
in a great place but
worry about you just drop in just let it
happen I don't know how to drop in Mel
you've got to stop gripping
the medicine is working just just trust
what it's trying to teach you
so then I spent probably three hours
going what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
like why can't you just enjoy this why
can't and I am just
is this going to work is it not gonna
work well why don't you just lay here
and enjoy the music why do you have to
be so intense about everything maybe
this isn't supposed to work like that I
reach for again I don't think it's
working I really think that you should
give me more because Mel
it is working
because you need to learn how to let go
and I said but I don't know how
and she said exactly
and then I got what I needed because
this is what I said to her
well I have to figure this out
because if I don't it's gonna be over
and I'm gonna have missed the whole
[ __ ] thing
and the therapist paused and said yes
just like your life
um
and
it made me
just stop for a second
and I thought to myself in that moment
I'm like okay
you're
a person who's had fun and you've
laughed a lot and you've done some
amazing things
but have you allowed yourself to really
enjoy it
have you ever truly now
like just allowed yourself
to receive
all the things that are around you
whether it's the beautiful sky that you
see as you're out hiking
or it's the people that are around you
in this moment
and so back to the original analogy we
were talking about rich like is there a
closed door that shuts you off and keeps
you trapped with yourself going it's not
enough and I got to do this and you know
there's no people here in in southern
Vermont and why did I do this and is
this going to be bad that'll triggered
by this alarm
or can you have a different experience
in life
where you truly are okay
with what's happening
and you allow yourself
to be content and you allow the love to
come in
can you get there and I'll tell you like
it just
by then dropped in
and there were no visuals
I just
it was almost like silence
and that's when that campaign of misery
really
kind of
and what was interesting though is that
the very next day you know we we're
doing our integration therapy afterwards
and I couldn't get off the couch I sat
on that couch rich
for two and a half days like didn't get
up and I felt this almost like energetic
shedding
of generations of [ __ ]
of this you know I come from a long line
of farmers
and my grandparents were from Austria
and had a family like super hard working
everything was always about work
everybody always had dirt under their
fingers everybody that they're bitching
about the cows or the pigs or this or
the that or the hooded lots of laughter
but work work work
and I felt this
just shedding
of
that I don't even know what it is that
wiring that just cloak that was around
me
and that's
it hasn't left yeah I was gonna ask what
is the half-life of these experiences I
mean I think
you know to your point like the
integrative kind of therapeutic
process that follows those experiences
is really the the key piece and I say
that as somebody who hasn't done this
and I have a lot of baggage and opinions
about you know those experiences and I
as somebody who hasn't done it
um but I'm always curious like you know
I know I know people that do Ayahuasca
like all the time they're not
enlightened like so what are they
getting out of it of the so-called
medicine what is what is the lasting
impact versus the transient kind of
experience that's cool and perhaps opens
a door or a window into you know uh some
some insight about how to live but how
do you then integrate that into your
daily behavior in a way that stays with
you it's an excellent question like I
think it's all about your intention is
it escapism
is it a cool experience or is it
something that you really are doing to
truly integrate some type of profound
change into your life
and for me
um you know I've spent enough of my life
trying to escape it and run away from it
and now that I'm 54 today
I'd like to spend the next half of my
life or however much time I have really
in it
and how's that going
um well I've only been in it now
you know it's up and down I mean first
of all happy birthday I was going to
open this by saying happy birthday we're
also here on the day after you launched
your new podcast
um
and I know a lot of work went into that
I mean there's I mean come on there's a
lot of handwriting that in the you know
the back story to this thing but also
that's gonna flare up the
competitiveness and the measuring
yourself against other people and all
those external forces that that Rob you
of being present in the experience and
and just you know that that sense of
gratitude or just you know being that is
antithetical to
um your disposition right so how does
that like in the in the in the wake of
this launch yep how is that showing up
for you how is that MDA MDMA experience
buffering against
your you know default settings it's a
great question so
um
I think the single greatest thing that
helps me
other than the work that I'm doing from
the neck down to stay in my body and to
stay in the moment and to recognize when
the alarm goes off and then to quiet it
is to stay deeply connected to the
reason why I do what I do
and there's a couple things that that
we've put in place
that act like guard rails for when I get
way too when I get triggered by
why aren't we on new and noteworthy on
Apple we're number 12 like when we walk
in here we're number 12 on all of Apple
podcasts right now you were number one
for a minute yeah you launched the
trailer I was like Jesus Christ you're
taking up my valuable real estate in the
education category by the way but you
know I'm happy for you Mel uh sure
there's enough success to go around
that's the one thing that I've I've
certainly learned it's taken me a long
time that there's room for everybody I
really believe that and the reason my
mission is super simple it's very very
much a the same as yours it's to help
you create a better life
and
selfishly my mission is that I wanted to
get off the road
I wanted to stop feeling so lonely
and I wanted to be able to
connect with people and share my life
and the things that I'm learning
in a much more personal and real-time
way that I can't do in an audiobook and
I can't do on a stage you know giving a
speech and I can't do in a 60 second
reel
and I I don't know if you know this
about me but I got my start in local
radio no I knew that yeah yeah and so I
I you know back when I hosted this local
radio show it was like a Lifeline during
a really difficult time for me and so
I've been wanting to get back to Radio
podcast it's just interesting that it
took you this long because it's such an
obvious you know low-hanging fruit for
you
yeah you know I guess the reason why it
took me this long is because I knew when
I finally was going to have a show of my
own
that I wanted it to be the thing that I
was doing I didn't want it to be another
thing I was doing
I wanted to make a deliberate
intentional decision that I was going to
change my entire business and organize
the entire business the rhythm of the
week and what I was focused on on the
podcast show and so it took me 18 months
to complete existing contracts to finish
up the stuff that we you know had on
Deck with audible to
hire the right people to figure out what
we needed to do and so that's that's
also why
I wanted to go all in and
um I think particularly when you look at
in personal development
the fact that there's an enormous
opportunity for female voices and
they're lacking you know I want to see
more and more and more it is incredible
I mean there's there's Glenn and Doyle
and there's brene Brown and then it just
kind of drops off precipitously from
there like it's wide open
yeah for powerful female voices
I agree and so
um
the way that I protect myself from it is
we I just stayed tightly connected to
the people whose lives were changing and
who are impacted by the content that we
put out and so one of the things that we
do that I love as we send out a daily
email that's a Roundup from all
platforms the inbox of things that real
people have actually said about the
stuff that we're doing and the impact
that it's made and so and today on my
birthday my team had uh tricked me they
said that Tracy was working and could
not join us for breakfast and when I
walked back to the hotel room they had
printed out birthday messages from
people in our community from all over
the world
and so and their photos and and so and
last night like at the at the restaurant
we were at there were four people that
came up to us and they all worked at the
restaurant
and one of the things about me and I
know this is true about you is I have
zero interest in Celebrity I have zero
interest in celebrities and it's really
you know just sort of like normal people
that are doing the best that they can
just like you and I are that's the kind
of people that I want to connect with
those are the folks that I really want
to be able to be somebody that can
make you feel like somebody believes in
you that you can do it right uh the
danger being for you of course that
nature abhores a vacuum and you
mentioned you know you wanted to go all
in like I'm an all-in guy right so what
does all in look like like how do you
not repeat the historic pattern of you
know filling that vacuum with a lot of
noise and busyness yeah and wrapping it
in a bow that says yes but I'm launching
a podcast and I need to do this for now
and blah blah blah and whatever else
only to wake up a year later or two
years later miserable once again yeah uh
with a with a faint recollection of some
MDMA experience that you had two years
prior do I hear cynicism from ritual is
that what I'm hearing well my baggage
you know my baggage is that I'm a
recovery guy right and so and I've said
this many times so I don't want to
belabor the point for people who've
heard me say it too many times but you
know when you tell a recovering drug
addict that this solution to his problem
or or a solution to the problem it lies
in a very powerful mind-altering drug
like that is that's that's uh that's
intoxicating in and of itself that idea
right so I will obsess oh this is I have
to do this this if I do this then
everything will be fine and that Loop
can be very destructive for me I
I have no judgment on people whose lives
who that have been improved I know lots
of people who have had similar
experiences and whose lives have been
made better by that it just scares me
personally because of my history even
though I know people in recovery who
also have explored this and had you know
a positive outcome from it well I think
that's just me like you know like
putting my cars on the table on that
yeah I think you have to pay attention
to that and and I think it's it's
enormously responsible and an act of
self-love to say that and it shows how
self-aware you are and if you were to
ever explore something like that as your
friend I would hope that you would
explore it with a therapist that
specializes in a particular I mean you
know what I mean if I if I was to
entertain it and I'm not you know
completely
you know putting it off the table but it
would have to be in a highly regulated
environment with people who are super
experts yeah I didn't I didn't hop on a
plane and go to Peru with travel
bloggers and you know sit around and
look and just go to Venice and you know
oh really well you know there's plenty
of it around but I I you know if that's
what somebody wants to do then that's
what they should do that is not at all
what I was interested in I was not
interested in a recreational
transformational experience I was not
interested in a burning man situation I
was interested in addressing specific
things in my marriage in my past in my
own well-being with right a guided
therapist and with my husband and with
therapy afterwards and it's interesting
now that like like why why MDMA and not
psilocybin or now they're using ketamine
for similar purposes
um I didn't want to do psilocybin
because when I was at Dartmouth I had a
horrendous experience on psilocyte
and um I think we basically bought
morels that had been dusted with LSD or
something because I was tripping my ass
off in a canyon trying to put my hand in
a fire pit because I thought there were
dancing Chipmunks in there and I was
living on like uh uh oh what the hell's
the name of that band I was living on
like an album cover fish and it was
terrifying and for a long long long long
long time I didn't even smoke pot after
that because I was so scared of that
experience and I am scared of a
experience on psychedelics where you
lose control and you're in a dark tunnel
like I don't need to take drugs
experience a giant frog chasing me only
to have the outcome be oh I can get
myself through this right but control is
at the center of your whole thing right
and so that experience in and of itself
is compelling you to loosen the reins
and let go which is a very uncomfortable
place for you right so are you telling
me I should do mushrooms no I'm not
telling you anything
I'm telling you that the struggle with
your second experience probably had a
lot to do with this control issue right
it had everything to do with not only
control
but for whatever reason
feeling like I'm not allowed to be happy
I had an experience as a child
of a parent who was never happy
joyful loud fun
but not happy
[Music]
and I absorb that and didn't even
realize it
and it's almost as if the closer I would
get to being happy
the more this sort of programming in my
mind that I absorbed as a child would be
like but no you're not
and so
I feel that after lots of therapy and
some of these physical experiences
facilitated by medicine facilitated by
other modalities
that's the Breakthrough that I'm having
like at a super deep level
that
it's okay
for me to be happy when somebody that I
love isn't it's not a betrayal
and that
you know it makes me sad because I think
for a very long time I didn't even
understand that I wasn't happy
and it's because of this silent campaign
of misery which is how I kept myself
company because it was there during
childhood and what about the fear
that
that comes up
around letting go of that pattern in the
sense that it's going to uh it's going
to you know destroy that engine that's
made you successful right like well if I
actually heal this and I'm happy then
I'm not going to have that motor that
drove me actually got me to this place I
think but did you have to deprogram
because I'm sure that you would pivot to
that right that idea
you know I I I I feel that the engine's
there I'm just giving it different fuel
so I like what if we all had a Hybrid
engine it could run on electricity or
gas so what's the fuel now like how did
you make that transition
a lot of therapy and a lot of like
dealing with this alarm
and allowing myself to have more and
more and like just kind of flexing this
muscle
of being in the moment being content
noticing when the but there's nobody in
Vermont
but why did you move three hours away
you're not going to have any friends
you're already busy enough
how do you think you're going to have a
new life you're three hours away from
your kid what are you doing
like catching that being like you know
what it's okay
you're gonna be okay it's like
you're in Vermont who cares
so here we are it's your birthday yeah
oh you know what you didn't you asked me
how are you gonna make sure you don't
have busy yeah come in you said that
really like sarcastic and uh right yeah
like how is the vacuum three hours away
from an airport so I put a huge buffer
in between myself right but we had
conversations when you were wrapping
your head around how to do this podcast
and one of those one of the things you
were debating was you know I need to get
a studio in Boston yep you're living out
in the country and I was like don't do
that like
the Mel Robbins experience will be
enriched by The Listener knowing that
you're sitting at your kitchen table and
Somebody's knocking over a glass in the
background like that sense of you know
reality and and authenticity is so
important to what you're doing you don't
want to you know inoculate everybody
from that and then distract yourself
from the mission by getting all caught
up in a studio and fancy stuff and
what's it going to be like and all of
that and then you walked in today and
said I got a studio and flushed it yeah
but so here but so it's not this but but
I told you not to do it you did I did
listen to you and hear hear me out so I
agree with you
the whole intent for starting this
podcast
was for me to have a deeper Connection
in real time
with people
and to help myself through the podcast
and also help other people create better
lives and to also learn more and so a
thousand percent yes you also made me
realize that it's not actually a show
that you go anywhere to do
that you literally need to figure out
how to make your life podcasting and so
you had a enormous transformative impact
on me Rich but hold on but let me tell
you about the studio so what I also have
come to realize much like a Hybrid
engine
that can run on negative energy or
positive energy right
that can run on stress and busyness or
can run on strategic
disciplined like thinking and priorities
is I've also come to embrace the fact
that I am the kind of person that
actually needs two things I need the
Deep Quiet and isolation of Vermont to
do deeper thinking and to feel connected
to Chris and to Oakley and to do deeper
work
and to Exhale and to commune with nature
and I also need these moments and bursts
of the city and of my team and of
creative Sprints and that I can't do
that if I don't have an office somewhere
but I have to figure out how to not be
in that office every week I have to
figure out a business model so I can
create my so I can live my life and have
the podcast be part of it and I can have
a legitimate business that runs like a
business not out of the desk in my house
but at an office that is not my house
which is something I haven't done in
eight years right and you got like
whatever it is 200 miles of New England
Countryside separating you so that you
can't escape into that office yeah and
the other thing is is that I don't want
jumping on a plane to give a speech to
be the solve for that energy and that
that that kind of creative thing that I
need right I need my projects the the
challenge obviously then is
for someone who's trying to simplify
their life and be very focused to not
allow those externalities to fill that
void or that vacuum and then create all
the insanity that you are trying to get
away from how do you repeating that
pattern
I mean it's that's you know I've been on
a similar Journey with the whole thing I
mean this studio that we're in now is a
relatively new thing
um but
the good thing about it is that it has
allowed me to relinquish a lot of the
control and to empower other people and
that's been a huge learning curve for me
and to make it more of a communal effort
as opposed to you know I'm doing this
thing we're doing it which has been
great so there is a there's a there's a
release with that and a letting go
that's been instructive and I think
empowering for
the people that I work with here and
also for me as well that's freed me up
to do other things and I still hold on
probably a little bit too tightly you
know as you're finding out it's more
work than people realize to do this
thing it's really hard work to put out
good content in this format and to do
video yeah so you know but we've been
doing it for a long time and I feel like
we're in a really good space right now
and I feel great and you know I haven't
done MDMA but I have all these other
therapeutic modalities that I've relied
upon and have grown as a result of
embracing and you know I as I'm sure
people say to you all the time Malik
what's the what are you working on
what's the big thing where you know
what's the next thing or whatever I get
that question a lot and
I don't
there isn't really a net it's this isn't
driving towards something that I don't
already have like this is [ __ ]
awesome to be able to do this I want to
just be able to wake up every day and be
excited about it I have other creative
things that I want to manifest and
Express in my life but
but I'm not doing this so that I can do
those other things like I just want to
be fully plugged into this and to wake
up and recognize and be present with
what an amazing thing it is and one of
the mantras that I've been practicing is
just saying remember like this is the
good time like nothing is static there
will come a day where I don't want to do
this anymore or this won't be happening
or you know some intervening event could
occur that derails me who knows what's
going to happen but right now like it's
great you know and I'm having fun and I
can provide for my family and I can
employ people who seem to enjoy working
here like what is better than that to be
excited about what you get to do every
day and to share it with people that
enjoy it and are nourished by it like
it's [ __ ] awesome
this is exactly why I'm watching you
podcast
but you know the other thing that
happened for me
um because you know you and I also share
the fact that we've been married for a
long time and you have four kids right
and we've got three
and the other thing that happened for me
rich is that my family
said very loud and clear that they were
tired of our house being my work
and so as we made the move from outside
of Boston to Southern Vermont where our
son is going to the public high school
and where my husband's family has had a
house for 40 years
um
I really listened
and I they were right like I was never
not working because I worked at home and
so it was really important for me
to try to figure out and I I haven't
figured it out yet we're just got two
episodes out as of today like I don't
we're so new with this this is literally
I put my pinky toe over the starting
line of America and you're gonna do two
a week yep right yep yeah that's heavy
yep and uh that we stopped scaring me
like all of a sudden I felt the campaign
of misery coming up like oh God should
we have done two take responsibility for
your response me yeah [ __ ] you
um I'm not trying to trigger you I just
you just I didn't tell you anything you
don't already know
well you know what I wanna I really feel
that
I want to be out there two days a week
and I have a lot to say
and I didn't want it to you're you're in
you're the best as far as I'm concerned
at interviewing people period And I
wanted to do a ton of solo stuff and a
ton of stuff with my kids and husband
and friends and so part of it too was I
wanted to have an episode every week
that was deeply personal
and then an episode that was more me
learning from yeah I'm curious about
that I mean I feel very comfortable
having conversations with other people
but if I was just sitting here by myself
trying to do a solo episode that's about
the most terrifying thing I can I'm not
good at that that is not my you know
sweet spot at all it's very
uncomfortable for me it obviously suits
you perfectly well but on top of that
you you know you only have two episodes
up but the second episode involves your
daughter and a very personal issue and
I'm curious about how like how you know
the relation like how you feel about
including family members and I mean
obviously they're willing to participate
in all of this like I just know my kids
like they wouldn't want anything to do
with it they're doing their own thing
good for you Dad but like we don't want
our personal laundry being aired out on
the podcast and like respect like
totally totally understand totally so
um boundaries
so how I handle those boundaries I don't
want to turn my
family into a reality show however
there are
things that happen every day in our
family
that happened in everybody's family
and so take Kendall who's a senior at
USC
uh she found out the other day it's like
two weeks ago that a guy that is her ex
just casual relationship during college
fizzled out they're not together but he
now likes a friend of hers and they're
all in the same music program
and
this went down in real time as she is
blowing up my phone with texts about
this and I texted her back and I said
would you be willing to talk to me and
could we potentially tape you know and
can I tape it
and we maybe use it as a podcast episode
and she writes sure
and here's the boundary I've put in
place with my family
you do not have to do this you can
always say no and say no all the time if
you want and you also can listen back
and will listen back
to whatever we tape
and you get to decide if you're
comfortable or not with this and so for
example there are a couple things that
we've taped with our 17 year old son
that are about things going on at school
for him the issue that we taped was
about
uh him wanting to drop a friend
who's really offensive but he's part of
a larger friend group and all the drama
involved with that and that is what I
would call a melting Ice Cube moment
that situation that's unfolding in real
time as we're sitting at our kitchen
counter and he's asking me for advice or
we're just talking through it
is something that everybody can relate
to so we'll capture that but I wouldn't
air that this year might not air it next
year I'd wait until he's out of high
school so that it doesn't impact people
in our community right so the episode
that just went up with your daughter yep
you know it's been up a day yep you have
to assume that it's gonna leak out and
her friends and classmates and whoever
else is going to hear this or be aware
that this exists and that obviously
impacts how she's going to be able to
navigate this whole thing yeah but
here's the thing like it is so past
she's already dating somebody else like
but she and and the thing is is that the
episode is not about it's not love
Island like we're not trashing anybody
she's calling me to process
in real time
that wave of emotion that hits you when
you find out that your ex likes a friend
or you find out that you didn't get that
job or you find out and you now are
wrestling with which version of you
right how to respond how do I respond to
this because the truth is she doesn't
want to not have them in her life
she also doesn't want to feel the [ __ ]
she's feeling and so how do you in those
moments when the emotional tsunami hits
how do you find your power and so what I
am really proud about in that episode is
I'm not even giving her the advice
she's actually unpacking it in real time
for herself as she's going do I not
collaborate with him do I do this am I
upset do I even care I actually want
these people in my life and I'm
realizing that they're better musicians
than I am which is making me feel
insecure because maybe that's why they
like each other and now it makes me like
so there's so much in there but what I'm
so proud of is first of all that she's
comfortable sharing it secondly that
even if you're the two people I would
imagine that she talks so nicely about
both of them
and at the end she's happy for them and
she has risen above her own insecurity
in turmoil
to be able to conduct herself in a way
that allows her to get what she wants
which is to remain friends with people
collaborate with them and open the door
to new possibilities and wouldn't you
know it five days later literally an
amazing human being walks into her life
what I got out of it and what I found
instructive was
um this sort of
instructional audio uh about how to help
somebody navigate through a problem and
disabusing people of the idea that that
like oh here well how do I say this here
comes Mel she's the one who's gonna tell
you you know what's wrong and how to fix
it and you know the parent is supposed
to come in and tell the kid what to do
to solve the problem
instead you illustrate the more
effective
path which is to
uh of empowering Somebody by just asking
questions and providing space for them
to process it so they can arrive at what
is correct for them right like it's not
like I'm not going to tell you what to
do but let me ask you this let me ask
you this let me ask you this and just
kind of retreating a little bit into the
background
and allowing them to or you know hit
that you know stick that Landing which
is the most empowering thing you can do
and it's difficult as a parent because
you do want to solve the problem even if
you can clearly see they should do this
and not that it's very difficult not to
just say that well that's one of the
things that I've been working really
hard on is not trying to solve my kids
problems and not trying to fix anything
because I've learned the hard way that
my kids don't want my advice
they want me to listen
they don't want me to come with my
daughter the other day because I I
stepped right into that trap yeah well I
I use steal this sentence for me I can't
remember who I got this from but
literally anytime they're upset or
whatever or they're blown up
do you want my advice or would you
just want me to listen nine times out of
ten when I say that sentence they're
like I just need you to listen
and then when they're done blah blah
then they'll typically go what do you
think I should do and I'll be like do
you want my advice or do you just really
want me to validate what you just said
and it's amazing how much they're mostly
seeking connection and validation
not the solve and I think if you get
them talking you know ideally you want
to raise independent human beings that
have the ability to think through an
issue and come to a decision after
considering all different options and I
really appreciate
what you just said about the experience
of listening to that second episode
because
I agree with you I don't sit here and
say I have all the [ __ ] answers and I
don't want this podcast to be preachy or
know it all that's not at all like how I
relate to myself I feel like I'm
shoulder to shoulder with everybody and
it's way more illustrative and
empowering I think to hear that
conversation unfold
than to have me recount a story oh so
let me tell you my daughter called me
and this is what she said this is what I
told her to do and this is the tool she
said way more relatable to hear that
actual phone call and an interesting
thing is that so this morning when that
episode went up
our website has been flooded
with questions about like because
there's a form for submitting topics I'd
say almost every other one is how do I
create a relationship like that with my
kid
how do you and I don't even feel like
the expert on it like I don't I don't
[ __ ] know like I I would actually
bring all three kids on
and say parents are writing in saying
how do you create a relationship like
that what's your advice to parents
because you're on the receiving end of
whatever it is that Dad and I did what
do we do right what do we do wrong what
is it that they're listening to because
what they're listening to I think when
you hear the episode with Kendall is you
hear the fact that she trusts me
and I respect her
and she's willing to share all kinds of
intimate details about what she's
thinking what she's done who she's
intimate with very freely
that's not something that happened
overnight
that comes over time and I don't even
like I I wouldn't I don't think I even
know how to boil that down it would have
to be them saying what created that
mm-hmm
what does your instinct tell you though
um
I think my instinct is
um probably you know one of the gifts of
the work that you and I do and how much
therapy we've both engaged in and
self-reflection and self-work is that
you do stumble upon really interesting
research that's very
um
informative
and I think more than anything else
Chris and I have this philosophy
that our kids are not extensions of us
we do not own them
we do not control them as our as parents
our job is to help them figure out who
they are
and how to make decisions
and how to live with the decisions and
accept the consequences of them and so I
think we've done a really really good
job of
trying
to emphasize
who you are as a person rather than the
outside [ __ ] so like for example here's
a tactical thing and I don't remember
where I where I got this but whenever we
would go into a parent teacher
conference
and they go to talk about work Chris and
I literally go we actually I don't need
to see their schoolwork don't need to
maybe that's how we missed Oakley's
dyslexia for years but we said tell me
about who they are at school
tell me about the kind of person are
kids
and I'm way more interested in
developing kids that are kind that are
self-reflective
um
and
I don't know I think I think oh oh and
then the other big thing is just like
all the growth mindset stuff I think I
think it actually works when you praise
a kid
for their effort and for their trying
and you know as crazy as it sounds
I also think about like
parenting kind of like training a dog
like you don't train a dog by beating it
and correcting it all the time you
actually reward the good behavior
and so if you want to see more kindness
call it out and model it at home
and there's a dispassionate kind of
disposition that you have to have when
you were talking earlier about you know
disentangling yourself from generations
and generations of a certain way of
being that was tied to workaholism and
busyness and drive and the like as much
as you know as much work as you put into
that like I know for myself in my weaker
moments like that still eeks out and it
eeks out in my parenting and so to
parent from a place of relative
neutrality where you're not projecting
that ancestral [ __ ] onto your kid I
think is super key and when your
daughter calls you up there's a sense of
feeling safe and not being judged right
like you're not evaluating her you're
just listening and that's it's a it's
difficult as a parent I wasn't always
like this yeah I don't I definitely was
not always like this I think that
um
it really all started I think a huge
breakthrough that Chris and I had was
was when we really thought
how are we going to address the issue of
daughters and sex
and we took a very
um
probably radical approach
I decided that I was gonna address it
head on
and so you know I don't think that we
talk enough about pleasure especially
with young girls and so what I did is I
basically I basically uh kind of
hijacked the conversation and sat our
girls down when they were age
appropriate which probably 12 or 11
maybe even early I remember right about
when they were doing the sex edit school
and what do you know what do you want to
know okay great now let me tell you sex
is one of the best things about being an
adult it's amazing especially when
you're having sex and making love to
somebody you care about and who deeply
cares about you
so here's the deal when you
are in a relationship with somebody very
special
I want you to come to me and Dad
and tell me when you're ready to have
sex
because we will then take you to the
gynecologist you will make sure you are
protected and
when you're ready to do it and you have
your protection we'll leave the house
you can have the house you can be in
your bedroom because it is something
that is so amazing that we want you to
have your first experience with somebody
who is worthy of it and you're worthy of
that and you're not ready to have sex
something that's incredible unless you
can actually tell us you're ready
and what's incredible is your kids are
like wait are you telling me to have sex
oh no like are you actually saying I
should have sex but there's some grenade
that goes off in their head what if they
came back a month later great okay what
makes you think you're ready
how do they treat you that's funny
because the person's ever been at our
house
so why do you think you're ready
yeah if this is what you really want
okay
but there are ways to continue to but
you you re you you shower them with the
praise
for coming to you
see most of the times our kids come to
us and we're like you shouldn't be
drinking you shouldn't be doing this
versus take a deep breath even though
inside you're like because when you know
she came to us both of them same thing a
couple years later is like okay I'm
ready they've been in long-term
relationships and you're like oh my God
I'm not ready but you are honoring the
fact that they're going to do what
they're going to do
you want them getting relationship
advice from their [ __ ] friends
or do you want them actually coming to
you yeah do you want them to be safe or
do you want them in the corner of
somebody's basement during a party
keeping that channel open is everything
and not judging
what they bring to you is the hardest
part because you're kind of wanted the
channel doesn't stay open if you're
judging totally that's the thing totally
so that's that created this kind of
opening
that
um you know I remember when one of our
daughters was being intimate with
somebody just like you know how did how
do you like give a [ __ ] and I'm like
ask your father I don't know like what
feels good and she did Chris was
mortified but of course anyhow about it
that just feels like a episode of a
sitcom or something well you know but
here's something
to their friends
would be a very popular episode of the
Mel Robbins podcast well I'm sure we'll
I I I if you approach that I want to
have this conversation with her kids
because
most parents
want to just turn their heads and be
like my kid's not drinking they're not
doing this they're not doing that and
when you make something taboo first of
all they never tell you what's going on
and secondly you make it more enticing
when you say you have permission to do
these things within guidelines
and uh with respect
they start to respect themselves yeah
we've had this experience with our with
our 18 year old and and she is open to a
fault like oh my gosh she'll come home
and oh man you should see what's
happening and it's terrifying right but
I think it's also important to
understand and appreciate that just
because you're doing that doesn't
necessarily immunize yourself from the
problem like there will be you know it's
like these are fraught years and stuff
happens and [ __ ] like that so when that
thing happens to not then get activated
and you know regress away from that
whole approach that got you to the open
communication Place one of the other
things about regulating that alarm
inside you is a lot of times your kids
bring you alarming things
and we've all had an experience of
working for a boss or having a parent
that when you bring news it's
disappointing or upsetting they freaking
vomit on you
and their emotional reaction is actually
what you're afraid of
and so
Chris is way better at this than I am
Chris is yoga instructor meditation
instructor he also now is studying to be
a death Doula dude oh wow
um a long way from being a restaurateur
no kidding yeah and so
he is Mr chill
non-reactive able to just hear and be
with and I've learned a lot from him and
I think that non-reaction
is incredible because it is a freaking
gift
when your kids share their lives with
you
it's a gift when people that work for
you feel comfortable coming to you and
talking about the stuff that's not
working
it's a gift that somebody feels safe
enough and linked and connected enough
to you
that they will bring hard things to you
and so that's the thing that I have
found to be like super rewarding about
managing my own [ __ ] in terms of the
reaction
and the marriage is good
you know depends on the day yeah uh no
the marriage is really how many years
you've been together 26 years Mary how
about you guys
22. yeah the theme that Chris and I have
been working on a lot is that
um we're really good not surprisingly at
the doing
and we're and it's not a situation of
being roommates it's something almost
deeper because if it's roommates it
feels like I don't care about you
but our lives have gotten so much about
the puzzle pieces yeah especially as the
kids have flown the nest and they're all
over the place
that we were both very emotionally
sequestered
from one another
so you know we're doing all this stuff
together but we're not wanting to burden
one another with the things that we're
wrestling with in our own journals or
with our own therapist or and and the
issue that we've been unpacking in
therapy is that if I'm the kind of
person and we've talked a lot about this
busyness
where I am so going all the time
that I quickly take care of things and
quickly do things and quickly jump ahead
and Chris is a person that
is easily provoked to
take a step back
as I'm doing doing doing part of my
campaign of misery is going why is Chris
not doing this stuff and as Chris is
sitting back he's feeling unfulfilled
because he's like when I can never make
her happy so why like I'm just gonna go
on a hike I'm just gonna do my thing
and so we over the last couple years
particularly you know as we've been in
the process of moving and building this
place for two years we definitely have
gone into our emotional corners
not in a way that's like I hate you or
but just this sense of loneliness that
we've both felt
and so we're really good right now
because I feel that through having a
therapist that we talk to once a week
it's in what a gift
to be able to kind of have a place to
come to to say
that like one thing happened today our
son has been sick for four days they
were supposed to fly out today for
parents weekend
for my birthday for the podcast launch
and we pulled the plug last night
and we were able and now have the tools
to talk about what is the right decision
but to also take a moment and check in
with each other about how you're feeling
because I'm sad you know I'm sad that
they're not here and I also know I can
be two things at once I can be sad that
they're not here and I can also be
grateful
that Chris is home with Oak and that
they're making that decision not to get
on a plane I mean he's coveted negative
but the kid's really sick
and
I can also prioritize finding time to be
with him when I get home next week
and you can focus on what you came here
to do without distraction and maybe
that's a negative you know busyness
oriented kind of perspective but I even
feel myself thinking like
yeah but she's here to like launch this
thing and now she can just do it and not
be worried about
you know other people's needs yeah it's
tough man like being together for a long
time I mean I definitely relate
to a lot of that like Julie's super busy
and she's got her startup and she's you
know putting together this Retreat she's
taking people to Egypt and I have things
that I'm interested in doing and you
know we we birthed a lot of creative
projects together but over the years
we've kind of you know we have our own
respective Corners now and there's
something great about that like we each
have our domains and we support each
other completely but it is a lot about
the puzzle pieces and you know all our
kids are still at home and they're
somewhat independent like they're kind
of like the boys have girlfriends I
never know when they're there when
they're not there and Mathis has a
boyfriend and she's gone a lot too
um
but there is a
uh you know a Transit Authority kind of
role that you're playing a little bit
and and uh it's very easy
to
lure yourself into believing that you're
communicating because you're talking
about those things yeah you actually
have nothing to do with your
relationship yes so there is an
autopilot and and with that kind of
autopilot you can delude yourself into
thinking everything's cool and it's
static but it's not really static if
you're in that place you're regressing
yeah and that's something I always have
to remind myself of because we have you
know been in places where it's like Oh
Our Lives are you know we're living
separate lives right now like we need to
sort this out and you know get back to
the intimacy that you know
is is why we're together in the first
place well for Chris and I it became an
even deeper and more or urgent
opportunity and directive because what
I've discovered is that you know kind of
trying to break apart my own reaction to
that alarm and trying to outrun it and
always being busy right and Chris's
reaction to his alarm is to retreat we
actually in many ways our default
patterns were keeping one another
trapped in those patterns and so there's
been a real opportunity that we're now
showing up differently I mean 28 years
into knowing somebody which is super
cool
so that Chris is more of I my code name
is trip leader because as I was trying
to think about what are the moments
where uh I am most attracted and feel
the most connected and safe with the guy
and there's two images one is anytime we
go on any kind of outdoor adventure
Chris is in [ __ ] charge man that guy
is Mr Knowles Mr outdoor Wilderness Mr
experience education and then there's
this other image I have of him where
when we first met we were in New York
City and I was meeting him for a date
and he came rollerblading
in a suit down Fifth Avenue weaving in
and out of traffic with a messenger bat
on from work and he just looked like he
was a kid at Play
and that's the guy I want and that's the
part of him that that really makes me
come alive but my [ __ ] busyness
it sends that dude into the corner
and so I'm working now both for my own
happiness
and my own boundaries with work and my
own ability to enjoy what I'm doing I'm
also working on breaking that pattern
because it allows a part of Chris to
step forward that he has not been able
to do because I've been such a dominant
[ __ ] and how's it going I mean can you
turn it off can you be at home and not
work yes yeah it's really good good I
have really good boundaries with my
phone I mean I'd like to get to the
point where as of 5 30 6 o'clock I'm not
working noon on Fridays not working I
put boundaries in place with speeches
it's a no unless it's middle of the week
and something I want to do in a direct
flight
um only to a month
yeah that's good yeah I'm I'm trying I'm
I'm taking the tools the tools only work
if you use them Rich right
I hate that that's true I do too I want
somebody else to do it for me Mel I know
you just fix it I don't like that too
although I don't think either you and I
would never be happy
doing nothing
right but isn't that the ailment like
that's
that's the place to go to understand why
it is that you can't just be like
shouldn't we be able to just be happy
doing nothing even if for a moment well
I can do it for a moment an evening
defined moment for an extent a week on
vacation you know a i i yeah I think I
could for a month but after that now
I've gotta put my brain onto some yeah I
mean I I take a month off every year now
I have not I've never done that and I
know that you do and I also know that
you go off the grid for a while there's
a lot I'm I'm I'm stalking you rich yeah
I'm I'm highly recommended Rich rolls
best now I look forward to it and it's
been very nurturing and it's allowed me
to you know remain enthusiastic about
all this stuff you have to take breaks
well I feel like moving to Vermont is
very much like that yeah but you can
occupy your interior space with your
busyness and it's true you know delude
yourself because you're geographically
you know remote from a city that you're
you know that you're dialing it back
when in fact you're not it's true the
tricks we play you know me well yeah
um well the last thing I want to talk to
you about is this idea of temporal
landmarks you talk about this in the
first episode explain
explain this to me and then you know
maybe I'm going to push back here I
don't know let me see okay yeah well so
there's this thing that researchers call
the Fresh Start effect
which is this uh moment typically in
time
that
opens up sort of this inspirational
aspirational behavior and thinking in
all of us and they have studied the
Fresh Start effect and again there's a
million examples of how this works but
in the studies around the Fresh Start
effect they talk about
specific dates and experiences that
create this moment where you break from
your past self and you literally feel
like you have a fresh start and so the
perfect example of this is January 1st
on January 1st you turn the page on the
last year and you you know flip the page
and it's a brand new year
and they call dates and experiences like
a birthday or January 1st or the
beginning of a school semester or a
sports season or for some people a
Monday for other people a fiscal year
that opens up they call these temporal
landmarks and a temporal Landmark is
something that gives you for a moment a
break from the past it opens up a new
window of time where you consider the
future
and you consider the future you
and so you know a great temporal
Landmark today's my birthday is the
moment when they're going to bring out
the cake
and there are the candles
and as I close my eyes and I blow out
the candles what do you do
you make a wish right and have you ever
noticed that when you go to make that
wish you no longer hear people singing
because you are taking a break from the
moment to consider
a bigger possibility
and the same thing happens on January
1st and the same thing and so these
temporal landmarks are something that
naturally occur in life they happen when
somebody dies they happen when you get
married it's these sort of new chapter
effect if you will and for just a moment
I'm not saying that the motivation is
sustained I personally think that the
Fresh Start effect that we all can
relate to when you make a birthday wish
is more about your willingness to see
something Beyond where you are rather
than the motivation to make this [ __ ]
happen
yeah I think it's about
ceremony and ritual right like when you
inject a certain date or event with kind
of a ceremonial energy it opens up that
portal for you to reflect a little bit
more deeply on your life and cast your
gaze forward towards that better self
um unfortunately the human brain is
wired in such a way that these things
you know have a very sure back to the
short you know the the half-life of
these things right like it's it's a
Trope at this point it's not even worth
discussing well I I disagree because I
think you could actually through a
ritual
create these sort of temporal landmarks
in your day-to-day life right that's
what I'm saying I mean we can there are
January 1st your birthday Etc but the
choice resides within you at all times
to make that different decision if you
want to decide that tomorrow is the day
that you're going to create that ritual
and ceremony you have that opportunity
we just don't you know it's harder and
we don't generally I do this is one of
the reasons why morning routines are so
important because if you get intentional
about setting up your morning almost
like it's a series of temporal landmarks
that trigger you right and that creates
a sustained focus on these things that's
gonna put you in a better place to
actually move the ball forward correct
yeah correct it's [ __ ] hard though
right well that's why you have to listen
to the ritual podcast every week because
no you just need to do the things
temporal landmarks yeah but you know you
can listen to the podcast as a
distraction from actually doing you know
the actual things that are going to move
your life forward I call that personal
development porn yeah there's a lot of
that right
I don't know man well what is why don't
you why don't you take us out with uh
you know some sort of
uh
inspiration or maybe a tool for the
person who is stuck who maybe has made
that birthday wish or had that
experience of a withering
um
uh New Year's resolution you know not
really panning out for them like how do
you get people to uh basically turn
right rather than left to use your
parlance from episode two that was
Kendall's that was Kendall's right and
left
um you know
when you sum up advice
it sounds so stupid
and so simple
but I do think a lot about alignment
and I think a lot about how so often
because we are resigned
or we convince ourselves that there's no
hope there's no way this is going to
make a difference the problems are so
big there's no like without the actual
kernel of Hope inside you
which I do believe even if you're stuck
you still have that there is this it's
almost like a burner on a furnace
although sometimes those blow out the
ones inside a stone
and there is inside of you this desire
to be happier
and I believe that the reason why you
want to be happier is because you miss
being happier and you can only miss
things that you know
and so that tells me that it's within
you
and we want to make it more complicated
than it is but I'll give you a simple
exercise that you can do that I did with
one of our daughters after she graduated
from college and two years of it had
been imploded by covet and she basically
uh dealt with the depression and the
grief by drinking herself into the
ground and you know putting on a ton of
weight and becoming very sedentary and
then she just had a complete breakdown
after she graduated
and so she was sitting with Chris and I
and we were just listening to her as she
cried and she's like I just don't know
what to do
I'm 20 you know one years old how do you
how do you how do you get unstuck how do
you do this I said okay well here's
where let's start here first of all I
want you to have this breakthrough where
you realize you do know what you need to
do
so take out a piece of paper
and I want you to draw a line down the
center
and now I want you to think about
when was a time that you felt happier
than you feel right now
and she said senior year in high school
so that was like four and a half years
from the moment we were talking about
and for some people it might be some
moment in childhood it might be high
school it might be last year I don't
know I said great now on the left hand
side of the paper
I want you to write down
all the things that were happening in
your life then like what did your
day-to-day life look like well like what
time did you get up what did you do
during the day what did you do near the
end of the day how did you spend your
weekends until she starts right I left
the house at 7am I was at school all day
with my friends I went to lacrosse
practice five day you know five days a
week I drank twice a week I was looking
forward to college
I exercised every day like just boom
boom boom and I'm like great now write
down what your life looks like now I
sleep till noon
I drink every day
I don't leave the house
I don't exercise I'm like compare
um
and change accordingly
and what happens in life and I'm guilty
of this too is we get so overwhelmed by
how big the distances that we need to
travel in order to change our lives that
we miss the solution that's right in
front of us which is your whole life is
about those little things that you do
every day
and if you're not happy get out a piece
of paper draw a line down the center and
write down the things that you were
doing when you were a happier or
healthier person
and add one in tomorrow
and if you simply just
get out for that walk or buy yourself
those flowers or start texting a friend
today to make plans or you
I don't know
put your name on the list for one of the
Huts for the national park in the spring
so you have something to look forward to
your life contains the clues to what
actually makes you feel a little happier
and when they're sitting there on a
piece of paper
and then you take a piece of duct tape
and you tape that sucker to the wall
next to your bed so that when you wake
up in the morning you see that there's
the roadmap pick one of those damn
things
you'll slowly start to feel better and
if you can feel better today you can
feel better tomorrow and that day that
you slip up and revert back to the old
version beat the [ __ ] out of yourself
yeah just beat the hell out of yourself
tell yourself see I sucked useless
useless it never works out for me Heap
on the self-criticism grab the alcohol
eat your face off sit in your house
isolate that's what you should do okay
no what you need to do is recognize that
you're a human
and to be human means that you are going
to have days where you don't do what you
said you're gonna do rich I have not
exercised like for real in a month
not at all of course I feel like I know
I look relatively you know skinny but I
feel so bloated and disgusting on the
inside I know what I need to do
I need to get back into my rhythm there
are things that work for everybody and
here's the major mistake we make you
talk about it all the time
we
let our feelings
dictate what we do
and we have to do the opposite if you
want to change you have to lead with the
actions that align with the way you want
to feel after you've done the actions
you have to
take action first because if you allow
your feelings of I'm tired I don't feel
like it it's hopeless why bother that
feeling will dictate you doing nothing
and that's going to keep you on the
right side of that page
if you just look at that list that you
created of all the things that you know
you should be doing that would just
uptick your happiness slightly or make
you slightly healthier slightly less or
slightly that
then
act like the person
on the left hand side of the page
and then every time you take that action
your feelings will fall in line and
you'll start to feel more like that
person you know I don't I I know I feel
bloated I know I'm not exercising I
don't [ __ ] care right now
because I've got something else that I'm
focused on in terms of this podcast and
the move to Vermont and you know Landing
the plane so to speak and I also know
that the second I get home on Wednesday
of next week I'll get back into that
rhythm
so why on Earth would I beat myself up
right now
don't because that is the reason why
you're not motivated
the research is conclusive that when you
are critical of yourself
it
destroys all motivation to act
and so if you have a bad day
congratulations you're breathing you're
a human being please do not beat
yourself up
Shake It Off look at your list and pick
something you're going to do tomorrow
and take the next right action correct
powerful Mel Robbins coming in hot with
the mood followers action wisdom on her
birthday nonetheless
say it's my birthday
I love you Mel thank you for coming by
today
and sharing your birthday with with us
you know I can't think of a better way
to spend my birthday and to get to spend
two hours with you ritual and it was my
honor
to drive here in fact I uh would fly
across the country and drive those 45
minutes to an hour because it is a
privilege to be able to sit in this seat
and be able to spend time with you and
to have the generosity
that you are giving
to me and to everybody else by sharing
this conversation with people that
really love and respect you so thank you
and I will respond to that by simply
saying thank you you're welcome and
I'm so excited for this podcast it's
going to be massive it already is huge
it's already a success right out of the
gate so I will throw it right back on to
you
um to say that you are an amazing
servant to humankind and my hope for you
is that you can truly enjoy the process
and not get caught up in the
externalities
because this is the good time now this
is the good time yeah right now so come
back I will on the other side let me
know how it goes very cool thanks Mel
love you I love you cheers
[Music]